in the opening scene we are introduced
to a 21 year old guy named Tim Lake who
resides in Cornwall near the Seas he
lives with his retired Father James his
busy mother Mary and his free-spirited
younger sister Catherine Kim narrates
that his family has a daily tradition of
going to the beach for tea and enjoying
movies in the yard every weekend
regardless of the weather in the next
scene the family organizes a New Year's
Eve celebration party which Tim isn't
particularly enthusiastic about during
the event Tim and his best friend Jay
accidentally stumble into a table
causing drinks and bottles to spill onto
some guests later Catherine hooks up
with a man named Jimmy Kincaid while a
Charming young blonde woman shows
interest in Tam when the countdown to
midnight Begins the woman leans in to
kiss Tim but he instead shakes her hand
and wishes her a happy New Year the
woman is clearly disappointed by this as
others around them exchange kisses with
their loved ones for her the ball that's
dropping is blue the next day Tim is
summoned by his father for a private
conversation as Tim has turned 21 James
discloses a significant family secret to
him explaining that the men in their
family possess the ability to travel
back in time to moment that they have
experienced before initially skeptical
Tim gradually realizes that his father
is serious to provide evidence James
instructs Tim to enter a dark space like
a closet close his eyes clenches fists
tightly and concentrate on the precise
moment he wants to revisit by doing so
he will find himself transported to that
moment doubtful but intrigued Tim enters
the Wardrobe in his bedroom to test this
he focuses on the previous day's party
and to his astonishment finds himself
wearing the same outfit from yesterday
surprised by this new foundability Tim
walks into the party once again and this
time he avoids bumping into the table
when the midnight countdown commences he
confidently approaches the blonde woman
and shares a satisfying kiss with her
following this Tim returns to the
present and discusses more about the
time traveling ability with his father
James mentions that he has used this
ability for many things in his life but
not for money or fame but certainly to
bang your mom many a time to me he also
advises his son to do the same Tim says
okay except for the mom part and decides
to utilize it to enhance his romantic
life as the summer season rolls around
Catherine's friend Charlotte pays her a
visit and Tim is instantly captivated by
her one day while the girls are
sunbathing Charlotte asks Tim to apply
sunscreen to her back the Shiner had
becomes excited at the opportunity but
when he squeezes the tube an excessive
amount of sunscreens sunscreen squirts
onto Charlotte's back causing an awkward
moment feeling embarrassed Tim hurriedly
retreats to the house and enters a
closet traveling back in time to that
exact moment this time he approaches the
task with more caution and gently
applies sunscreen to Charlotte's back if
that sunscreen tube wasn't a euphemism I
don't know what is in this life on the
final day of Charlotte's visit Tim
gathers the courage to go to her room
and confess his feelings unfortunately
she informs him that he shouldn't have
waited until her last night and that he
should have expressed himself earlier
this prompts Tim to travel back in time
again to disclose his feelings to
Charlotte in the middle of her stay
however she once again rushes him aside
saying he should wait till her last day
in reality she is just trying to ignore
him heartbroken Tim eventually realizes
that regardless of how many times he
travels back in time he cannot change
someone's decision or feelings after the
summer vacation Tim moves to London in
order to pursue a career as a lawyer he
resides with Harry an acquaintance of
his fathers who is a bitter and cynical
playwright Tim begins working at a law
firm and befriends a young man named
Rory while also searching for a
girlfriend unfortunately luck doesn't
favor Tim and six months pass without
any romantic prospects in his life one
evening Tim and Jay visit a restaurant
called Don's Le Noir where they are
paired up with blind dates in a dark
room during this unique experience they
meet two girls Mary and Joanna Tim
spends the evening engaging in
conversation with Mary while Jay
interacts with Joanna Tim and Mary flirt
in the darkness and their conversation
indicates that they're enjoying each
other's company later when they meet
outside Tim is captivated by Mary's
Beauty even though she doesn't perceive
herself as particularly attractive
consequently he manages to obtain her
phone number before parting ways
following this Tim happily returns home
only to learn that Harry's new play went
horribly wrong it turns out the lead
actor forgot his lines determined to
help him Tim travels back in time and
attends Harry's ongoing play When the
actor struggles with his lines Tim
discreetly holds up cue cards from
backstage helping the actor to deliver
his lines perfectly as a result the play
goes smoothly and eventually becomes a
success however this action also leads
to a big problem when Tim attempts to
contact Mary he realizes that his time
travel has erased the evening he spent
with her in a desperate attempt to
gather information about Mary he rushes
to the Don's Lenoir restaurant but his
efforts proof fruitless the next morning
Harry comes across a glowing review of
his play in the newspaper coincidentally
Tim notices an advertisement featuring
Kate Moss triggering his memory of
Mary's fascination with the famous
celebrity in light of this Tim decides
to visit an ongoing Kate Moss exhibition
hoping to find Mary there after a week
she finally appears and Tim seizes the
opportunity to approach her they've
reintroduced themselves and begin to
reconnect but Tim discovers that Mary
now has a boyfriend consumed by jealousy
starts probing for details about how
they met which turned out to be a party
hosted by Joanna once Tim gets all the
information he needs he travels back in
time to alter the course of events in
the next scene he shows up at the party
quite early and before the potential
boyfriend arrives he then approaches
Mary who is sitting near the window and
initiates a conversation although things
go awkwardly for the first few moments
Kim manages to persuade her to leave the
party and have dinner together
preventing her from meeting the new guy
dude got cocked by Doctor Who and
doesn't even know it during their first
date Tim brings up the topic of Kate
Moss and as the conversation unfolds he
learns that Mary works for a book
publisher after an enjoyable dinner Tim
walks Mary home and upon arrival she
invites him inside where they start
making out being their first time it
doesn't go smoothly so Tim remembers the
sunscreen tube and decides to travel
back in time to relive the experience
which turns out to be more satisfying
from that day onward their relationship
begins to Blossom and Tim eventually
moves in with Mary One Fine Day Mary
surprises him by him informing him at
the last minute that her parents are
coming to visit from America she
emphasizes that he must avoid mentioning
any intimate details about their
relationship as their parents are a bit
conservative but later Tim foolishly
blurts it all out leading to an
embarrassing situation feeling ashamed
Tim retreats to a nearby closet and
travels back in time to rectify his
mistake after this alteration the two
share a meal with her parents during
which Mary admits her love for Tim a few
days later Tim attends to play at a
theater where he notices Charlotte with
her friend in the audience after the
play concludes Tim approaches them to
say hello as the two talk Charlotte
reveals that she regrets rejecting his
proposal earlier she now wants to know
him better so she invites him for dinner
Tim happily accepts but once they're
done eating Charlotte unexpectedly
invites him to her place Tim realizes
that she wants to have coitus with him
so he politely declines and leaves this
encounter prompts Tim to realize the
depth of his love for Mary so he rushes
back home and proposes to her in bed
delighted Mary joyfully accepts The
Proposal the follow following summer Tim
and Mary visit his parents home and
introduce her to his family in a very
short period of Time Mary grows closer
to Tim's family who also develop a
fondness for her during a family dinner
Tim announces that they're marrying soon
and also shares the news of Mary's
pregnancy making everyone happy the
long-awaited wedding day finally arrives
and despite a storm disrupting the party
venue the ceremony is filled with
romance and laughter Rory serving as the
best man delivers an awkward speech
during the reception in response Tim
travels back in time and chooses Harry
as his best man however Harry's remarks
turn out to be rude as well prompting
Tim to travel back once more and
ultimately select his father who manages
to deliver a heartfelt speech befitting
the occasion a few months later Mary
gives birth to a beautiful baby girl
whom they name as Posey then the family
moves into their own new house despite
their struggle with finances Tim
narrates that their happiness overrides
any Financial concerns he also reflects
that time travel is no longer necessary
for him as he now cherishes and Embraces
every moment of his life the scene then
switches to Posey's first birthday where
Tim's family Harry and Rory gathered to
celebrate with the exception of
Catherine shortly after Jimmy shows up
and tells them about Catherine who is
driving drunk after an argument with him
it turns out that Catherine has
unfortunately met with an accident while
she was on the way to Tim's Place
terrified Tim quickly uses his time
travel ability and saves his sister from
her ill-fated Journey after the birthday
party Tim and Mary discuss Catherine's
predicament Tim realizes that merely
saving her from the accident hasn't
resolved the issues she faces including
problems with her boyfriend and her
drinking habits therefore he decides to
intervene in her life to prevent further
troubles Kim then Reveals His time
traveling secret to Catherine and takes
her to a closet intending to go back to
the New Year's Eve party where she first
met Jimmy this time he prevents her from
approaching Jimmy and they later see him
showing interest in another girl this
makes Catherine realize that Jimmy is
just a Playboy so she confronts them and
punches him in the face poor Jimmy who
has no idea who the girl is simply
stares disbelief following this the
siblings returned to the present were
the entire situation has been modified
and Catherine now develops feelings for
Jay her relationship with Jay proves to
be much healthier compared to her
previous one with Jimmy Tim is relieved
by this outcome and returns home however
upon arrival he shockingly discovers
that Posey has never been born and
instead he has a son concerned Tim
promptly travels back in time to the day
of his child's birth to seek guidance
from his father James explains that they
cannot alter events that transpired
before their children's conception
ensuring that the exact child will still
be conceived this means that if Tim
wishes to preserve Posey's existence he
cannot change anything that occurred
prior to her birth therefore Tim accepts
that he cannot alter his sister's Life
by modifying her past and allows the
accident to take place ensuring Posey's
birth while Catherine is hospitalized
Tim and Mary remain by her side until
she realizes that she must take
responsibility for improving her own
life Mary suggests that she should date
someone who treats her well and Tim
recommends Jay once Catherine is
discharged from the hospital Tim returns
home and is Overjoyed to reunite with
his little girl as he plays with Posey
he subtly indicates to Mary that they
should have another child though
initially hesitant they ultimately
welcome a baby boy into their lives two
years later completing their small happy
family one evening Tim and Mary prepare
to go out for dinner with the latter's
publisher for this Mary tries on
multiple outfits but feels dissatisfied
despite Tim assuring her that she looks
beautiful in anything finally Mary
chooses the very first dress she tried
on after getting ready they head
downstairs only to discover that their
daughter has accidentally destroyed
Mary's important manuscript Tim
contemplates using time travel to
rectify the situation but at the same
time they receive a phone call from
Tim's mother informing them that his
father has been diagnosed with terminal
cancer devastated by the news Tim Mary
and Catherine visit their parents home
while there Tim engages in a private
conversation with his father who
explains that time travel cannot cure
his illness since undoing his smoke
Habit in the past would prevent Tim and
Catherine from being conceived James
admits that he had been utilizing time
travel to extend his life and spend more
time with his family with only a few
weeks left to live James tells Tim to
live each day twice in order to be truly
happy first with all the everyday
tensions and worries and the second time
with all the sweet thanks Tim takes his
father's advice to heart and discovers
happiness in his life however there are
certain days that are better to be lived
only once like the day that his father
passes away on the funeral day as
everyone prepares to say their final
goodbyes Tim unwilling to Bid Farewell
travels back in time to spend a moment
with his father this provides him with a
small measure of comfort as he realizes
he can always travel to the Past
whenever he misses his father several
days after the funeral Mary expresses
her desire to have a third child Tim
initially hesitates because that would
mean that he could no longer visit his
late father however after thoughtful
consideration he realizes that his
ultimate source of Happiness lies in
being a loving father himself with the
woman that he loves with this he agrees
to Mary's Wish as nine months pass
Mary's due date approaches before the
momentous occasion Tim pays a final
visit to his father and mentions that he
won't be able to visit him anymore in
their final meeting the Father and Son
travel back in time to relive a
cherished memory from Tim's Early
Childhood ensuring that they don't alter
any experiences to preserve the
Integrity of the present that was
incredibly risky back to the present
Mary gives birth to a baby girl and Tim
gradually comes to terms with the loss
of his father elsewhere Catherine is
shown with her own baby having started a
family with Jay the movie concludes as
Tim Embraces his ordinary yet contented
life realizing the importance of living
each day only once from that point
onward he decides to stop using time
travel once and for all it's a touching
message but if Timmy didn't have time
traveling abilities he'd have never been
this happy so I'm not sure what I'm
supposed to do with it subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications tend to leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching